wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and get some
amazing inspiration from ian lavenze
enjoy
you don't have to be broke you don't
have to struggle
you don't have to be sad and sorry you
don't have to take care
of everybody just because you've always
done it
be willing to do a new thing in a new
way and sometimes you're gonna have to
piss
people off in the process
[Music]
sometimes
because people will hold you to your
limitations
they will hold you to what they believe
to be true about you
spiritual code of conduct says do not
believe that because it hasn't happened
it won't happen renew recharge your
vision
and do not be tricked into thinking that
because it's always happened
it has to continue to happen spiritual
code of conduct says
do not accept the unacceptable
do not accommodate and tolerate what
doesn't honor you
close your eyes for me for a moment and
i want you to hear
this i give
all meaning to everything
i see breathe
okay i want you to take that thought out
of here with you
so that as you go back into your life
that you remember i give all meaning to
everything i see
if i see myself as broken wounded
damaged crazy stupid whatever
i give meaning to that so if i want my
life to have a new meaning let me pick
thoughts and images
that support who i am when something
happens with a partner or friend and
even a co-worker or or supervisor and
you're bringing up
all the other times that you've
experienced that in the past
that's baggage when you start your
statements
about why you do something a certain way
or what you're not gonna do because of a
certain experience
that's baggage and these are just
common everyday things this isn't even
the hard stuff
so i want to give you some unpacking
skills
for just the common everyday normal
baggage that we walk around with these
human beings
if one person tells you you're a horse
you don't have to believe that if two
people tell you you're a horse
you you may want to listen but by the
time three people
tell you that you're a horse you need to
check yourself
because i bet you got hay hanging out
your mouth and your tail is wagging
in other words if you keep hearing the
same thing
from different people at different times
about you
you need to unpack that baggage and
don't hear it as
criticism or make people wrong or bad
ask them what they mean i remember when
my
my grandson told me that i was mean and
i had heard that but i never paid any
attention to it because why
i mean i'm not being sad i can't be mean
but when i sat and i listened to him and
i realized wait a minute he's not the
only one
saying that to me i had to hear it and i
had to unpack
it so when you hear one or
two or three unrelated people telling
you the same thing
don't dismiss them ask them tell me more
about that
because there may be some baggage that i
have to unpack
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief check
out my 254 series where every day for
the next 254 days
i will send you an unlisted video the
sign says it takes up to 254 days
of consecutive action build a habit so
i'm going to be with you every step of
the way
if you want to be on for free 100 free
is the link below
go check it out i'll see you there we
need to stop
whining about what isn't happening
so it's not selfish to put yourself
first no it's self-full
it's so full it's self-full to be first
to be as good as possible to you to take
care of you
but if you don't love what you do and
run for your life three things i want
you to do to nurture your vision
i want you to affirm it every day affirm
it every day
and don't affirm it is i'm trying i wish
i want to i am let me hear you say i am
i am i am i
am i am i am
every single day i am is the creative
force of the universe
whatever you attach i am to
you will become you know people say i'm
broke
or i'm single no
i'm waiting for my ideal mate to present
himself to me in a way that i recognize
whatever you attach i
am to i'm confused no
i am awaiting clarity in this moment
so affirm your vision every day and just
because somebody else can't see your
vision
doesn't mean that it's not a powerful
vision for you
here's another key for you never
judge your clarity on how
other people respond did you hear me
they're gonna say what you doing you
crazy why are you doing that you can't
do that
who told you you could do that who do
you think you are i love that one
who do you think you are me
affirm your vision clarify your vision
know what you're doing why you're doing
it
and how you're doing it day by day
moment by moment
and sometimes the how only shows up on a
need to know basis
don't wait for the how until you start
pursuing your vision
you understand don't wait for the house
sometimes you just have to walk blindly
but if you just do your vision every
single day
putting one foot in front of the other
committed to your desires being obedient
walking through your fears the vision
will unfold much
grander than you could have ever even
imagined
or asked for so this is what i say
to support your vision instead of
begging for it
pleading for it pray oh god please open
your please god please
oh god please please god please
oh hallelujah
be still
let your daily spiritual
practice be one of stillness
and listening listen
for the instruction instead of begging
for the direction listen
be still i don't care what it is that
you're doing in this world
i know many of you involved in the
government here and
we have so many elected officials and
people who are
serving the world in so many ways
but if you don't love what you do and
run for your life
[Music]
run for your life
if five days three days out of the five
you're doing your work you complain
more than you bless run for your life
[Music]
if you're continually looking at what
you don't have and what people aren't
doing
as opposed to looking how blessed you
are to be in a position to run for your
life
you got cooties and you need to run for
your life
do not act like you know when you don't
know
and do not act like you don't know when
you do know
some of y'all know you out of order as
hell
and you acting like
some of you know you don't need to be
out there buying another piece of fried
nothing
in that marketplace
you know right now your sugar high as
hell
sneaking around the little pole trying
to eat up that little piece of
uh praline put that thing down
[Music]
don't act like you don't know when you
know
and don't act like you do know when you
don't know
you know one of the beauties of me and
fix my life is people have become
willing to ask for help
we don't know so many of us
just don't know we don't know how to do
this
we don't know how to be successful when
they called me and told me
that they wanted my product on hsn they
told me i needed
a dun and brad street number i almost
peed on myself
what the done in hootie why
that's something the white people do i
don't know nothing about that
i read about that in the one wall street
journal that i read 15 years ago
but when you are growing
and living beyond the places that are
familiar
you got to be willing to do stuff that
scares you
and that's when you're going to have to
rely on your connection to something
bigger
greater and grander than you ask
for help do not be so willing to buy
real estate in what is comfortable and
familiar
in your own mind
as much as i'd done and grown and healed
there's still things that i need to
learn and if i need to learn it
we all need to learn it because we're
all just one
don't act like you know when you don't
know
ask for the help that you need and don't
act like
you do know that you don't know when you
do know
because you're convincing yourself that
you can't be trusted
trust what you know you knew
when you met boo
you know he was crazy as hell
[Applause]
you saw the crazy right round the edge
and you said but he cute
[Applause]
don't excuse crazy you just should have
crossed the street i told you that 23
years ago
when you see crazy coming cross the
street
why do we have to learn to trust others
because everybody is a representation of
god
how can i not see here's the thing human
beings are crazy as hell
they live messy lives but they give you
an opportunity to grow something bigger
and better in you
even if that something is a no
even if that something is enough even if
it's enough yeah
no you're not going to do that no we're
not going to do that no we're not gonna
have that
no you will not treat me like that you
know
so trusting humans is important
because they give you an opportunity to
to grow
that something you need gives them an
opportunity
to learn we like to be right yeah it's
like being wrong is almost a fatal
disease or something like it a
drop will die on the spot if we have to
say i was wrong
you know so so if we look around and
anybody
challenges us it will give up what we
believe so here
is one of the things that i learned on
my journey to peace
i don't need your agreement
i'm asking for your support
i don't need your agreement i'm not
going to get people to agree
with what you know in here cause they
don't know that they ain't in there
never judge your clarity
based on somebody else's response
when you're clear you're clear hold to
your clarity
and if people look like they doubt you
close your eyes be authentic
be authentic
many people don't even know what that
means
it means that you're clear about who you
are it's
you're clear about your purpose your
protocols and your plans
you're clear about what you're up to and
you speak
your the truth of that all the time be
authentic means you're in integrity that
what you
think what you say what you feel and
what you
do all matter now i know that's hard in
washington
because there's just some truth you
can't tell out here
but we want to do the best that we can
and when you can't
pray about it but be authentic
so many of us don't allow people to know
who we
are as i travel around this country i
meet country
people all over the country who are
suffering
in silence because they're not authentic
about what they need what they want
what they're doing what they're
experiencing the only thing you got to
do
is be happy about who you are and just
do you
do but how often do we forget that
how often do we forget that who we are
just as
we are is enough and we get busy doing
and being something else
and then we become unhealthy on all
levels mentally emotionally spiritually
physically because we leave the truth of
who we are in search of something else
in order to take the next step to where
you want to be you've got to be willing
to take a stand
for yourself within yourself speak up
for yourself
ask for the things that you want and be
willing
be willing be willing for some people to
say no everybody's not going to say no
you know people's job is not to make you
happy i know that would be wonderful if
this were
ian laville and all of you were iamala
heights and i could just be happy
you know so but that's not it so you
you've got to be willing to do that
take that next step towards standing up
for yourself
so those things that are unconscious and
habitual will begin to fade away
you've got to challenge them it is
amazing to me
how many people believe that they must
respond to
anything and everything that seems to be
going on
they measure their personal growth and
spiritual prowessness
by the number of adverse conditions
they've been able to live through and
with
some people even consider it a measure
of their faith and trust and good
in god when they struggle and suffer
waiting for something better to befall
them
can you imagine that people actually
believe
that if they can live through and
forgive the most dastardly deeds of
others
that they will somehow be rewarded with
a major outpouring
of peace and enlightenment well this may
be one path but i want to tell you about
a shortcut
duck i personally have learned
how to duck behind god when the crazy
starts flying
there are some experiences i no longer
choose to have
i accept that people won't like me they
will not agree with me
and they may not choose to see me as
any other way than the way they hold in
their mind
that is not my issue that is a personal
issue you know maybe we do have karma
you know things that we have to work out
between ourselves and the people
that show up in our lives well listen i
reserve the right to choose
how i'm going to participate and i
choose
to duck some people just want to fight
they expect a fight they look for a
fight and if there's no fight around
they will pick a fight
they want to argue and be upset and i no
longer consider
it a necessity to stand with them
or for them in the midst of conflama
that's conflict
laced with drama when family and friends
know that you have a
spiritual outlook they want to include
you
in their problem solving and we train
people
to come to us by always knowing just
what to say
and just what to do and just what they
should do
just because we can handle it doesn't
mean
that we must handle it or that it's in
our best interest to do so instead
we can choose to duck
dodge underdeveloped consciousness
kindly let's clean up our mouths
how we say what we say and who we say it
to
do you know you can talk yourself into
trouble
a lot easier than you can talk yourself
out of it
but if you become mindful about
what you're speaking it'll be a lot
easier to
handle some of the things that come up
in your life with
speaking years and years and years ago i
learned a secret
i used to open my pocketbook my purse
and i'd get right down over and i'd say
fill yourself with divine
substance right now
oh you look at all that abundance just
pouring down right out
i name everything and i speak to
everything
my car got a name i said gracie how you
doing this morning
come on we going traveling my house got
a name
villanova the big vision
i'm mindful of my mouth because i know
that what comes out of my mouth must be
created
everything begins with a word so
we even want to stop speaking about how
horrible our children are doing or how
bad people are doing or how bad things
in
here well here's his affirmation oh my
i can hardly wait to see the good that's
going to come out of this
no matter what it is as opposed to ewing
using our power to continue to affirm
what's wrong what's broke what ain't
working what's not happening
how horrible it is let's speak life
into things let's speak life into our
children let's
speak life into our families into our
relationships
i can't tell you the number of people
who write me and say
i need you to help me with my crazy
family well
they're your family
i don't even know that kind of crazy you
got over there this is just what i'd be
thinking and then i bless my head so
that that thought will go away
well what if we started saying wow i
know it looks like
boo boo my cousin is having difficulty
right now but i see a brighter day for
you
it's what emmett fox called gold keying
where you
key something up with the radiant
richness of what you want it to be
as opposed to affirming it as it is
right now
as it is right now so we want to clean
up our mouths
and what we say about each other imagine
that you have 24 hours
a day for how many years how much of
that time
do you give just for you will you just
sit
and be present with you self-care and
self-nurturing
also being really clear about what it is
you want
talk to yourself about it talk to
somebody you care about about it
hear your own voice and honor your own
feelings and
be good to you be clear
about who you are and what you're up to
at any given point in time be
clear about what matters to you
what you value what you will do what you
won't do
what you can do and what you can't do be
clear
clarity is a gift and it grows
and develops through practice be clear
be clear about who you are many many
years ago
when i first started doing this work and
i was writing i wrote a little
purple book called acts of faith and the
book had a life all his own
and i was running all over speaking and
talking about acts of faith
and and stuff and and and making money
on the book
speaking for fifty dollars and three
hundred dollars and two hundred dollars
i had to get clear
because i had on 500 worth of clothes
it was not profitable but i had to get
clear
and dennis kimbrough said this to me
right in the
halls of the old convention center he
said yamaza
be clear about what you are are you a
writer who speaks or a speaker who
writes
sometimes when we do multiple things we
throw them all together
and we practice each and we master none
be clear about who you are
about what you do what you're up to what
is your primary cause of action
and call to action you got to be clear
and
listening to what dennis kimbrough said
to me was i a speaker
who writes or a writer who speaks i said
well
i ain't none of that
that's something that i do but that's
not who i be
who you be you've got to get clear
about who you be because being is an
internal state it's not about doing it's
what drives you
what elevates you what you would do
every single day
of your life for the rest of your life
whether you got paid or not
that's who you be what matters to you
that's who you be what you value that's
who you be
and so many of us are clear about what
we have to
do but not clear about who we be
as we're doing it because some of us
want to serve people and we mean it in a
wet cat
on any given sunday who get
clear about who you be worry is really a
sign of control
people think they worry warts but they
really control freaks
they wanted to come the way they wanted
to come and when we can't control we go
into worry which
really is how we rehearse um
the worst thing possibly happening
that's what worry is
right you know it's like oh that's not
going to happen and then this is going
to happen and never have to you know so
worry
it's really a control freak issue when i
say get over it i'm defining i'm giving
you a process for
reclaiming the power of your mind that's
what i'm giving you
get give every thought over observation
validation uh examination and reframe
give every thought observation
validation
examination and reframe because too many
of us walk around
uh coddling and entertaining and
validating wow wow wild thoughts just
like rihanna said
we got wild things i know about the
honest i know about rihanna khalid all
of them i ain't
my youngins i got to keep my eye on them
i got to keep my eye on them yeah
so you know we we don't have the control
of our minds
that's why we it's looking like it's
looking i grew up understanding and
recognizing about
ancestral study and cultural nuances and
stuff and
my grandmother the same cherokee was in
the uh
kojic church
so we were coaging all day and then we
was
at the moon at night
i mean so it was it was good and not so
good because i mean what that taught me
was really to hide who i am
and that who i am is not really
acceptable
you know we we didn't talk about putting
plates down for the ancestors and
and doing all of those or you know
honoring the earth and what we do full
moon ceremonies but
as i grew up and i embraced my
matriarchal lineage as a yoruba
or my patriarchal lineage as
uh well into slakey but we really work
in the lakota tradition
and i became a pipe carrier for them an
initiated priest and an
ordained minister because the thing that
i found
is the commonality of universal law
and i live universal law in principle
the law of cause and effect
whether i'm just leki or lakota or
yoruba or kojic the law of cause of
effect
and effect is going to work principles
integrity responsibility accountability
compassion honesty those principles work
now the benefit that i have is that i
understand how they're
taught from a cultural perspective
you know whereas the the bible will say
you know thou shalt not lie
the yoruba will say um the king does not
lie
or the he who knows the truth has a
responsibility to speak the truth
and the lakota would say basically the
same thing if you walk in truth you live
in truth
then you bring the spirit of truth to
the planet it's the same thing thou
shalt not lie
yeah universal law i have it from a
cultural perspective so that's really
what it is for me
and i think for many people the thing
that's missing is
the culture so i teach it from the
universal perspective but speak to it
the way that i've lived it
from the cultural perspective i never
really aspired to happy because happy is
usually determined by
external factors i go for the joy
because when you have joy at home when
you have
joy inside it don't matter much what's
going on out here
you understand you got your joy and you
can come home to your joy
no matter what is going on in the world
far
too many of us have our happiness our
peace
our joy our value our worth
hooked into some external stimulation
and then we wonder why we're stressed
out and overweight and can't sleep
i learned a very powerful lesson last
year last year
i've never been sick a day in my life
not ever
i've never had a cold and i don't get
the flu shot
[Music]
i do my wheatgrass i do my prayer
i do my uh 40 days of
fasting fruit and vegetables once a year
from the
first of january to the middle of
february i do my things that i
my spirit tells me to do
so i went to jamaica last june
to to speak and uh there i just became
deathly ill i didn't even know i was ill
because i had never been ill
i thought i had food poisoning so i
would go and vomit and come back try to
speak to the people and go
throw up some more then i said well the
people is waiting i'm 20 minutes late oh
lord bring the bucket and put it on the
stage
[Applause]
so busy living up to the external
didn't take time to check with the
internal
so i got the bucket on the stage in case
i have an accident
like somebody would really pay to come
see that
do you think about what we think about
sometime anyway
so i'm there on the stage deathly
deathly ill
and finally i said to the people just
like i told you about my lipstick on my
turn
i said i got to confess something i'm
here telling y'all how to take care of
yourself and i am sick as a dog
i tell you what i'm going home i'm going
somewhere
and lay down hopefully this is food
poisoning and if i'm not dead tomorrow
i'll come back
how did you learn to fix your own life
and learn to trust when everybody in
your life
particularly in your family had let you
down
i started paying attention i started
taking copious notes to my own behavior
because i had a choice i could either
blame them and be
upset with all of them all of whom were
dead
pointless you know or become accountable
and responsible
they taught me to do the wrong things
but i voluntarily continued to do it
if i'm continuing to do the things that
they taught me
and my spirit is saying that ain't right
that's not right you know better you
know better you know better
so i had to start paying close attention
to what i was doing based on what i had
been taught
we don't have control of our minds we
we're hypnotized anesthetized and
desensitized
so get over it i want us to start
thinking about what we think about
consciously and i give you a promise a
process
to eliminate the things you're thinking
about that you don't want to think about
no more
things like a little taste like like
somebody you still mad because boo-boo
left you back in 56
1956 1956. that's a long time to hold on
to something yeah
but you know how many of us oh
lord come on come on we got time
do you not have to put it in this
context beloved because
i just you know i don't want people to
think it's shallow
your great-great-grandmother that's
great great
i'm a great but just in my time
a great great grandmother
didn't get to choose all the time the
man she wanted
because she was the master's woman just
a great great
she didn't get to choose who she slept
with she didn't even sometimes get to
choose
to keep her dern babies
we go to the bar and pick up boo-boo the
fool bring him home the same night and
give him a key and then get upset when
he leave
i can't take it i can't take it
so we got to start thinking different
and really understand the sacrifice that
we come from
the legacy that we come from not feel
bad about it not just be
mad about it but understand where we are
and then as dr diane akbar says elevate
the history
so that we can use the lessons in our
lives today
you must know who you are
look i'm not talking about your name or
your occupation
i'm not talking about what people say
about you on facebook
i'm not talking about your pin number
i'm talking about who
you are at the core and the essence and
the root
of your being spiritual code of conduct
says you have to know
who you are and that your behavior
cannot make testimony about you that is
not the truth
of who you are when you have a spiritual
code of conduct and when you know who
you are
if you ain't a hoe you don't act like a
hoe if you ain't a dead beat daddy you
don't act like a dead big daddy if you
ain't not gonna snipe you don't act like
a gutter slide
come on now you know who you are from
the inside to the outside
and your behavior is a demonstration
of what you believe to be true about you
spiritual code of conduct says know who
you are
when somebody calls you out your name
in your face so it's not selfish to put
yourself first no it's self-full
it's self-full it's self-full to be
first to be as good as possible to you
to take care of you
to keep you whole and healthy that
doesn't mean that you disregard
everything and everyone but you want to
come with your cup full
you know my cup runneth over what comes
out of the cup is for y'all what's in
the cup is mine
but i gotta keep my cup full don't we do
that
don't we take on other people's stuff
and make it about us when we don't know
that we matter
when you don't know you matter you will
make somebody else's crazy
about you you got your own stuff
to handle you don't have to take on
anybody else
people violate you when you don't have
clear boundaries
because you don't tell them how to
behave in your life
and they run amok they run amok
because you don't have clear boundaries
the real self
knows the truth no matter what mask or
what face you wear
in the world your real self knows the
truth
and there was a time in my life when i
acted like i knew a truth
that i didn't know and the truth i
didn't know
was the depth of my value and my word
you see i had already been an author
that had sold
over 6 million books 14 different titles
i had already been on my own television
show i had traveled around
the world i had spoken to hundreds of
thousands of people
and still i did not know or
value my own worth so in a very big
opportunity to go
forward and to be on what was once
called the oprah winfrey show
yes and i went on the oprah winfrey show
and miss winfrey
asked me back again and again and again
and eventually
i became part of her change your life
faculty and it was all good i had
written 13 books
i had traveled all over the country i
had done her show repeatedly
but i didn't know my own sense
of worth so what happened i tried to
live in a place that i didn't believe
was true for me
and eventually i crashed and burned
crashed and burned by leaving
the oprah winfrey show and going on to
another network
and doing another show that didn't even
survive a season
all because i didn't know my
work now it would have looked like all
sorts of external circumstances oh there
was a miscommunication between me and
miss winfrey
and the other network was offering me a
lot of money and why shouldn't i take a
big business deal
no it was about me not
knowing my own worth me not being able
to stand
in the miracle of being on the oprah
winfrey show
repeatedly among honored teachers
without having to work
hard for it because that was what
i had been taught the matter with me was
that i didn't know how to receive a gift
a blessing without working hard for it
so when things came to me easily i blew
them up
it's self-sabotage or procrastination or
forgetting
or whatever it is that opportunity went
away
because i didn't know my work that's the
kind of truth
we have to tell each other we have to be
aware of it we have to acknowledge it
and we have to accept it you have to ask
for what you want and don't
settle for what's available or what you
think you can get
say it again they told me say it again
a spiritual code of conduct says
that you have to ask for what
you want and do not settle
for something because it's all you think
you can have
or because it's what's available if you
want it single don't settle for it if
it's married
let me take a walk
[Applause]
if you want it easy don't make it hard
and if you want it hard then you gotta
work with it if it's not
ask for what you want and and
and ask for the things that are going to
uplevel
your wattage in life
don't stand off the things that are
going to dim your light
up level your wattage
sometimes our light be bright blind in
us
your light is so brilliant it blinds you
the reflection of it shining back in
your eye
and so you get confused and you'll be
holding on to things that do not
reflect your own brilliance
did you hear what i said that your light
your gift your talent
your truth can be so
brilliant that it blinds you
and you end up reaching out for
holding on to taking on taking care of
housing feeding clothing lending money
to stuff
that only dims your life often we teach
preach say what we most need to learn
what was it about trust that you needed
to learn for yourself
i grew up thinking that a woman was my
mother who was not
i grew up thinking that there was
something wrong with me
because of god only knows why
my life actually you explained why so
well
in reading about your grandmother i
think she was related to my grandmother
in all the ways that you make children
feel inadequate inadequate
bad i was bad yeah i was bad yeah i had
the devil in me
yeah had the devil in me and she was
gonna beat it out
because she was a woman who because of
the times in which she was raised
and the suppression and oppression had
learned that it was best to go through
the world keeping quiet keep quiet
be who they want you to be had i
knuckled down had i really given in
to the restrictions and limitations
placed on me
i wouldn't be who i am today was my
talking
that saved me here was the you know the
classic
shut up you talk too much shut up why
you talk so much you've always got
something to say
and today people pay me well to hear me
speak
yeah if i had shut up as a child that
may not have ever happened so you
learned that you needed to learn to
trust yourself
even when it doesn't feel good feedback
can be a really really good thing but
first i want us to make a distinction
between
feedback and criticism because i think
that's important
feedback is the energy or the return
energy of what's put out this means that
feedback is
information about or reactions to
our state of being and our performance
and our
our way of being in relationship
feedback comes to us as a response or a
reaction
or sometime as comments or a review
of what we do and how we show up at any
given moment
and feedback has a purpose the purpose
of feedback is to provide us with
guidance or direction
that will serve as the influence
for modification or change in our
behavior and in our energy so in other
words feedback
is a cue that something we do
or say or how we behave needs to change
that's all it is
now that sounds pretty harmless but but
here comes the challenge
most feedback either feels or
sounds critical which means that it's
going to
trigger a toxic memory or a feeling
which then motivates us to discount
the feedback we're receiving you know we
we can't even hear it
so so what is criticism then
if feedback is criticism what is
criticism
criticism is feedback that demoralizes
condemns judges or blames
it's feedback that is consciously
or unconsciously offered to manipulate
or control
that's the difference where feedback
is offered to motivate correction or
change
criticism is offered to manipulate
and control and in many many cases
while what people offer
as constructive criticism
what they want to give us it actually
criticizes us and that's what leads to
a mental or emotional shutdown and we
can
lose the value of what's being
offered because criticism is an offering
now here's the good news
all criticism is feedback
and here's the bad news all criticism
is feedback what i mean is this
whether it's positive or negative
productive or
unproductive all feedback is telling you
something
you need to know about yourself and what
you hear
and how you hear it has nothing to do
with who's saying it all feedback is
about
who you be and how you be
and it's bringing that to your awareness
there's something you need to change
beloved
whether it is coming at you from your
mother or your sister
or your boss or your coworker or your
partner
feedback is a source of information
for self-improvement and it can be
received and used
as the foundation for altering and
changing
your way of being do you have a morning
ritual
oh yes absolutely as soon as my eyes
open
23rd song as soon as my eyes open
i do it and then i usually go
i go sage my house out because i don't
know what was floating around in the
night because you know i live out in the
bushes like you
then i make my coffee i do love my
morning coffee
and then i read my um my
course in miracles lesson for the day i
read my jesus calling
and then i put my bible to my head and
open it
and wherever it opens that's what i read
and then
i go downstairs and sometimes i get on
the treadmill and sometimes i just dust
it off
but i always get on my
trampoline and do my 15 minutes there
and then i get on my inversion table and
i hang upside down
really yeah because to rush the blood to
my head and
keep me from getting wrinkled and then
i'm off for my day when we think we are
unworthy
it means that for some reason we believe
that we have to prove we have a right
to our space on the planet
in life as we are being who we are
and that means that we will do all
manner of
wonderfulness to prove we deserve to be
here
and usually some of the common things
are we over commit
over give we overdo we we
over excuse we over compensate
and we stay in difficult desperate
hurtful harmful situations
much longer than it is wise or
productive to do so
worth what it is that you
expect from the world in response
to who you are it's very different
from value self-value means
how you hold yourself within yourself
and what you expect
as a result now in order to get to the
world
if you're not holding yourself within
yourself as
worthy than what you expect from the
world
i recently spoke to a man who was about
to abandon
his path of spiritual study because he
couldn't seem to align himself
with the laws of life in essence he
couldn't make the law work for him
he had done all of the right things and
he had said all of the right
affirmations
he was praying and meditating and
listening still
his life was a mess surely he thought
that
i can't be on the right path and that
that happens to many of us we
do something for a certain amount of
time and we have an expectation
that there's a reward and when we don't
get it we think we've done the right
thing
perhaps he thought he should return to
the spiritual tradition of his
family listening to him i said been
there done that
i knew exactly how he was feeling
suddenly i remembered that in the midst
of my own spiritual breakdown
a good friend offered me something that
i was excited to share with this pilgrim
in distress
we must make our spiritual
practice personal it is of
absolutely no use to read the words and
study the principles and look at the
book
as if they're magic formulas that are
going to bestow something on you
every word you receive as guidance on
your spiritual path
must be received as if it was written
specifically
for you whether it's the bible or the
torah or the quran
the bhagavad-gita you have to know that
these words are coming to you at this
time
for you next you must make all of your
spiritual practices
and insights practical you do not need
wings and feathers
you need to walk on earth be heavenly
bound but be good on earth
you must hear and receive spiritual
teachings
in a manner that addresses right where
you are
just as you are right now
it is so tempting to think that you've
got to wait for something in you
around you to be different before you
can apply
what you're learning and study a better
way to interpret
what you receive when you read or when
you study is to put it in the first
person
make it an eye frame of reference by
applying it to
something that's going on in your life
right now
next you must believe that the answer to
your prayer
is possible whether you've been praying
it for 15
days or weeks or months or if you prayed
it this morning
because the minute you entertain the
thought just one thought
that everyone's prayer can be answered
but yours
the possibility for your prayer to be
answered goes right out the window
all things are possible to those who
believe
so make your belief and the things you
believe in
personal and practical
and know that they are possible if you
really
really love someone respect them enough
to tell them the truth and believe that
they can handle it
i know i know i know sometimes we lie to
people
because we don't want to hurt them we
lie to them because we're afraid of
their reaction
we lied to them because we think that
what we've done is so horrible or
what we feel is so disagreeable or what
we
want from them will never get but
love requires honor honesty
and truth and if you tell a lie
and get caught it'll create more hurt
more harm more upset than if you just
told the truth in the first place so
if you really love somebody and you want
to
maintain an honorable honest
authentic relationship love them enough
to tell them the truth and believe that
they can handle it
and if they can't oh well tell them the
truth anyway
your purpose is to serve
but you don't do that for the women you
do it for you
okay let me just take the truth
you don't serve for the other person
you do it for you that's your purpose
the fact that they benefit is gravy on
the potatoes
but standing in your purpose that's the
potatoes
so you don't do it for them you do it
for you and that makes you uncomfortable
to say i'm serving for me didn't make
jesus uncomfortable
[Music]
may be providing support
for women as they empower themselves
the minute you say my purpose is to you
can't empower nobody
if i left you here for 24 hours with a
bag of lace potato chips
how powerful would you be over that bag
but one of them obviously would jump out
into your hand and my hand would make it
to your mouth
and you know you can't eat just one
so what i want you to do my darling is
get
comfortable with serving as your purpose
and don't dictate what it looks like
your vision may be that you'll serve
women by supporting them as they empower
themselves
that may be your vision but your purpose
is serving
take your control off and let god send
you where you want your god
like being with because i said i want to
do women
i suppose that's not what god wants you
if you really want to reach your
greatest potential if you want to see
just
how far you can go in life if you've got
a dream you've been holding on to in the
back of your mind
and now you're ready to risk everything
for that dream
if you really want your life to move
forward
you must be willing to make some people
mad
oh people will get mad whenever you live
beyond
someone's opinion of you or they're
going to get mad
whenever you begin to think more of
yourself
than people think of you oh they will
get mad
whenever you move into a place
of being in a way of being that other
people around you
are afraid to try on for themselves
they will get mad and so what
they get mad their madness doesn't have
to influence
your life you've got to be willing
to live through the difficulty of
upsetting
people you care about of people that you
really thought
were on your side turning their back on
you
and whatever when you get there
those people that really need to be
there will be there
and the others won't really matter the
players
don't stop to pick up trash
on the field
that's what we have to learn in taking
the next steps
in our healing don't stop
to pick up trash on the field
[Applause]
let me let me tell you what trash on the
field is
number one stop reminding yourself
of how badly you did in the past trash
on the field
trash on the field it is not
helpful to keep reminding you
of how that didn't work unless you're
looking at it
for the value of the experience trash on
the field
number two stop reminding yourself
of what you haven't done just because
you haven't done it doesn't mean you
won't do it
but you got to get focused on the end
zone
number three make sure you know what
ball
game you playing before you start
playing
okay because sometimes we start playing
the game and we don't even have a clue
trash on the field you'll be picking up
trash on the field you'll be thinking
that you got to do certain things you're
obligated to do certain things
because you don't really know the rules
of the game there are three rules
tell the truth be
clear get focused
and stay that way taking the next step
it
really isn't as hard as you're making it
we all have a tendency at times to make
things more difficult
than they need to be and that need not
be here it is
it happened you didn't like it
it was a violation of your boundaries it
didn't honor who you were
somebody didn't keep their agreement or
you failed to make
an agreement so there's nothing to hold
anyone accountable to
you felt bad about it they felt bad
about it now you're left feeling bad
but it doesn't have to be hard here's
the choice
let go and move on or hold on and stay
stuck
it's just that simple it doesn't have to
be
hard you get to choose let go
and move on or hold on and stay
stuck so i have this thing that i've
been promoting called no whining
wednesdays
wednesday you cannot whine complain
or criticize and people like well what
is wine and
whatever you think it is don't do it
and every time you do it you have to put
a quarter in a jar
if you whine about anything i can't i'm
tired
of me why don't you what happened
every one of them will cost you a
quarter or complaining
why don't you why do you always how come
you i always
they never cost you a quarter
then last week i had people send me
pictures of their jaws a quarters
oh my god but what they said to me
also was this was wonderful because i
was never
ever aware of how much whining
and complaining and criticizing i do
now i've got mothers doing it with their
children
so wednesday is no whining wednesday
we need to practice that we need to stop
whining about what isn't happening what
we don't have what we can't do
what somebody didn't do we got to get it
clean in 2014.
no whining no complaining
no criticizing keep it simple the
truth will cut through all the drama all
the misunderstanding all the hurt all
the pain
all the memories keep it simple
i don't care how long you've been with
fifi or boo-boo
if they leave you it's not because
something's wrong with you they ain't
the one for you
keep it simple you got laid off from
your job there's another divine
opportunity
waiting for you to keep it simple you
lost your house well in your father's
house there are many mansions
just hang around long enough
keep it simple
the path to greatness order
vision trust
[Music]
faith
a good piece of chocolate i got
something for you
refuse to fail
refuse
[Music]
just refuse to fail
and if what you're doing looks like it's
going to move you towards failure
do something else if you look at me
refuse to fail i refuse i refuse
to fail now that may mean that i have to
walk barefoot
it may mean i have to sleep in the park
it may mean that i have to ask for help
it may mean that i have to give
something up it may mean that i have to
stop but i
refuse to fail had i
knuckled down had i really given in
to the restrictions and limitations
placed on me
i wouldn't be who i am today was my
talking
that saved me here was the you know the
classic
shut up you talk too much shut up why
you talk so much you've always got
something to say
and today people pay me well to hear me
speak
yeah if i had shut up as a child that
may not have ever happened so you
learned that you needed to learn to
trust yourself and i love when you say
in here is that
you know there isn't a person you can
ask in the world at some point where
they didn't say
you know i just find it difficult to
trust people right
but what you say that's not really the
issue
learning to trust other people the real
issue is trusting yourself
trusting yourself that you're going to
make the right choices trusting yourself
that you can hear that voice and follow
it trusting yourself that when people
betray you
abandon you don't acknowledge you
whatever you will
i'll be okay yeah i'll be okay and when
i go back and
and look at it something told me
you know you say god throws a pebble
then he throws a bread
you got to learn to trust the pebble
when you hear it very lightly
yes when you hear it it's like yeah
that's it it shows up
like a bevel yeah yeah but we don't pay
attention to that
faith for me is the inner knowing
that dares your soul to go beyond what
your eyes can see
so sometimes i will get a hit or a sense
or an inkling or whatever you want to
call it yeah and i just
know and then when i'm not sure when i'm
not clear about it
you know i i know enough to trust who we
are matters
what we do matters how we do it matters
and therefore
we have to take responsibility for
everything that's going on in our life i
know i know i know i know
i know the crazy people set you up but
it was a divine
setup to give you what you needed in
order to grow beyond where you were
you can see the commonality in that
human experience what is
what is the wound that we're all
suffering from
that was separate from god of course a
miracle says you cannot solve the
problem
because you do not know what the problem
is the only problem you have
is the belief that you're separate from
god because if you knew
who lived within you and walked beside
you you could never be afraid
or angry or ashamed or whatever you know
your wonderfulness of humanness is yes
so that is it the belief that we're
separate
the belief that it looks like i'm
separate from you you're over there i'm
over here
that you know straits are separate from
gays blacks are separate from white
and our belief in that illusion and the
physicality
makes us think i can do anything to you
yes you know when i'm walking in the
supermarket now
i am your sister i'm a demonstration of
who you are
of who my grandmother was and that's
because of our oneness i see it and i
feel it
and i live it so that i know every time
i show up
i am a demonstration and a
representation
of past and future generations yes so i
got to be clear
the enemy is in me yeah i'm fighting the
world
i'm fighting that part of me that says
you can't do that
yeah don't do that and there's a part of
me that says come on we're going to do
this
and then the other part says don't you
remember what happened last time are you
going to do that
and you can't do it it's in me and
there's a part of it
that's where the real battle that's
where the real battle is that is where
the
crux and the core of trust comes
in those two parts of us the part of us
that would rather stay broke and
miserable complaining
you know living in the whatever the
mediocrity
and why why because we're afraid because
we get to control it
we get to control it i know how to be
broken poor
and struggle and suffer and and be angry
i know how to do that i got a degree
but when it comes to being open and
vulnerable because trust the core
ingredient of trust
is vulnerability yeah that's the core
being vulnerable going within
following my intuition and facing the
unknown
i'm not gonna taste the unknown because
i can't control the unknown
i can control the familia i can control
what i know
i'ma trust that even if i'm miserable
i'm a trusted rather than opening myself
to a greater grand of possibility that
requires me to be vulnerable
we'd rather have our own reality show
prostituting our pain
and dysfunction for a check than we
would
to really take care of our business and
i mean take care of ourselves and heal
ourselves
and and come together and buy a dern
network
we'd rather prostitute our pain and show
our thong
and fight each other and throw liquor
across the table you know because that's
interesting
hey um the ratings say that atlanta
housewives number one uh housewives show
right
so so we tune in the basketball wives
coming back for a new season because we
tune in we tune
in to our own demise we and i always say
we give people the bullets to shoot us
with
yeah so how do we stop doing that is the
question we have to want to karen
we have to want to and it's easier to
try to be dysfunctional enough to get
your own show
than it is to do the work to not be
dysfunctional
because to do the work not to be
dysfunctional and to look at yourself to
tell the truth about yourself
to look at where you lie life is as
instant as you are
if you make the choice today that you
want to be because it's not
you're not doing it for the other person
you're doing it for you do you want
peace do you want joy do you want to
move forward or do you want to be stuck
in the past
so you get to choose you don't want to
forgive dope i've got to know who i
am the first thing that i have to know
is that i am a unique demonstration and
and representation of the chief
architect and creator of the universe
all that god is i am i have to know that
i have to know that otherwise i'll
continue to believe in separation
spiritual code of conduct says
do not stay where you don't want to be
because you've convinced yourself that
you ain't got nowhere else to go
[Applause]
don't leave me out here by myself
[Applause]
all y'all are them jobs you hate
on a job you hate
hate it so much you can't even be
grateful that it's feeding you
hate it so much you can't even be
grateful that because of it
you got a roof over your head somebody
talk to me
you hate it so much till you go there
every day complaining
and you're meaner than a wet damn cat
you're so mad that when you get your
paycheck you waste your money
somebody talk to me over here i think
somebody right up in here
might need this message
don't put your face ugly with me if i'm
stepping on your toes now
i i i'm loving on you beloved
yeah don't stay where you don't want to
be
do your practice get your vision ask for
what you want
and be willing to do something new
that's what the spiritual code of the
condo says
impatience is another word is another
faith killer
impatience you know it takes nine months
to have a baby
you know and so it may happen in eight
and a half months it may take
nine months and two weeks but you can't
have a baby when you're only three
months pregnant you just
can't have it it's not gonna work it's
not gonna work
so impatience is another trust issue
where we're saying
you know we can't see it so we don't
know what's happening what's going on
and uh impatience is the abortionist
because impatience will lead you to do
things that will abort the dream
abort the vision abort whatever it is
because if you you know if you cut just
the womb open while the baby's
developing you're gonna abort
so impatience is the abortionist of of
good things
so how have you found a way to align
yourself with the seasons of your life
instead of acting as if
every single day is output output output
impregnate yourself with the vision and
the intention first
i made that mistake i
got all caught up in oh i got to do 30
cities i got and we got to do the
marketing and we got to do
this and like out on the west coast the
tickets weren't selling and everything
and i was like in freak out mode and i
thought it was because
phoenix had a lot of white people they
didn't want to come see me so
i was writing a good speech for the
white people to come here as if the
white people knew i was writing a speech
and they didn't know and then you know i
got i got convicted in my spirit
and i hadn't sat down i hadn't created
division
i hadn't created the intention i was
focused on selling tickets and not
delivering the message
so i had to correct myself so i would
say to all young women
whoever you are because you know giving
life bringing forth life whether you
have children or not is not the issue
the issue is that we bring forth lives
so before you do anything
sit down and get the vision impregnate
yourself with the vision
and then impregnate yourself with the
intention
i'm not on tour at my age
because i need to make money or sell
tickets
i'm on tour at my old ass age
business
and i didn't realize how old i was until
i got to city number three and i was
like okay
i'm dying oh my god in 99 you know i did
26 cities like this
that was a while ago yeah i'm on tour to
speak
into people's souls not through the tv
screen
i have a message that i have received
from the ancestors in the holy spirit
and to speak it into their soul what i
discovered
is the reason many of us don't
experience the full benefit of
forgiveness
is because we do it begrudgingly we do
it out of force
and we do it on one level in the mind
but in order for forgiveness to truly
anchor in your body and free up your
energy
you've got to forgive the thought the
feeling the belief
and the action got to forgive on all
levels and most of us are just forgiven
intellectually
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you watch a video and you get
motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place
and how you're going to actually take
action on it you jump to 91
chance of following through and when you
have public accountability and you
commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you do not allow things and people
to diminish your light
do not hold on
to things and people
that diminish your light
do not hold on
to things and people and beliefs and
ideas
and pathologies and traditions that
diminish your light
everything you hold on to has to up
level you
everything listen
now let me just say this
excuse me elders forgive me what about
saying that
now if you got you a little sex toy
whether it's living or mechanical
you don't have to let that go
[Music]
you don't have to let that go
cause it's gonna upload your wattage
make you happy
[Applause]
long as it don't belong to nobody else
did i share sex toys with other people
[Applause]
oh everything don't have to be holy and
spiritual mission
if your sex toy ups your wattage hold on
to it
don't let it go
[Applause]
i ain't talking about that i'm talking
about holding on
to anger and shame and guilt
and lies people told you about yourself
that you believe
i'm talking about holding on to
unforgiveness
i'm talking about holding on to upset
i'm talking about not forgiving your
mama and your daddy
and your baby daddy and your baby mama
and the teacher
and the lady that crossed her eyes that
you crossed the bank
window that's the kind of stuff i'm
talking about
i'm talking about holding on to it
coulda
and it shoulda and why they didn't and
why she did
i'm talking about holding on to that
kind of stuff and sometimes you don't
even know that you're holding on to it
it's in your energy it's in your
subconscious mind
it's in places that you can't even get
to that's why you gotta pray
that's why you gotta call in the light
that's why you gotta call in the energy
that's why you have to have a
relationship with something bigger
greater and grander than you i'm talking
about holding on
to the lies we have been taught about
ourselves
and a system in a country that continues
to diminish
deny and throw away our genius unless
it is beneficial to them y'all better
get clear up in here
if you want some amazing motivation from
lisa nichols check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there that's just the
circumstance that i came from
that's not what defines my future i just
believed that
not a lot validated it but faith is
believing in the unseen anyway
so i had enough faith